ça va très bien fait voir à huy le
sautoir vous ne sais pas ça égaye les
coûts d'un tel vote et moi si tu es
parfait approche main dans la main le
petit foulard faut cacher la griffe là
tu sais je vais vous dire ma petite
michelle catherine je pense que c'est
une très bonne idée de s'être habillée
comme michel catherine me permettez moi
de vous présenter moselle arlette
pilchard qui est notre emballeuse
première catégorie ordaz le squer
n'arrivait pas dans les coeurs sont émus
dans les cartons voilà l es salaam
orwell et pittoresque et alors voici
monsieur plan fut notre sémillant
délégués du personnel n'est ce pas si
dévouée si efficace
toujours prêt à défendre les
revendications de ses camarades
bonjour monsieur le moenner bonjour
madame attaque va présenter un
syndicales au nom et au nom de mes
camarades et moi même nous sommes là
pour négocier et pour manger
d'ailleurs à ce propos à propos de
l'atelier paie cash oui nous allons nous
a offert un nouveau coup terre alors on
a toute la soirée
un même temps ça va bien comme ça ils
sont impatients 1
aussi et aux revendications immédiates
ce rapport à la machine à café parce
qu'elle est toujours en panne la nôtre
marche rassurez vous mais on va pas
commencer par ça que diriez vous d'un
petit apéritif 1-1 qui au royal royal on
mais vous êtes folle voulait la
révolution où avais je la tête
oui mon mari a raison pas de mélange que
duo ou un bon mais moi j'ai fait le
charme puis je vous à pierre harmel oui
mais vous là monsieur plantules à côté -
eddie bo vous mettez des relais à
monsieur le directeur il s'appelle
thibault oui c'est modibo monde ibo
monty bon ben ça va bien installés nous
fait comme chez nous c'est très joli ce
que vous avez là ce petit clip c'est
quoi ça c'est la faucille marceau tout
le monde là le film c'est le badge de
lusine mais pourquoi tant d'efforts mot
thibault alors oui ça fait chic au
rotary
pensez plutôt les odeurs voulez que je
vous donne un coup de main dans la main
michel catherine e.on mais vous n'y
pensez pas ma petite harley qui vont me
disais justement renvoyé la banque
ça fera plus peur mais de mai mais je
n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais dit je n'ai
jamais dit ça c'est non j'ai simplement
dit que le dialogue serait plus
cordiales si nous étions entre nous
comme ça mais à propos de dialogue et au
sujet de taille et b4 qu'envisage le
patronat au niveau des cas d'un c'est la
cinquième semaine de congés
oui alors vous vous faites vous faites
bien d'évoquer ce ce problème épineux du
bk et je suis très heureux de pouvoir
vous annoncer devant ma femme est devant
mademoiselle pelchat qu'il est en passe
d'être résolue de la manière la plus
satisfaisante qui soit puisque aussi
bien dès lundi le b 4 sera fermé si fils
est en cause il est ouvert ce tome la
secte a même ouvert mais le bk télé
fermé et d'autre à part côté vous
augmentez les augmentations des primes
de risque je vous pose la question mais
vous en pour vous avez vous avez bien
raison de la pause et a lancé dans
l'agglo parce que pas plus tard que tout
à l'heure j'en parlais avec michel
catherine 1 mais non messi mais non
mais si mais si ici ni sort alors tout
l'été que le proc le problème de
l'augmentation des primes de risque et
très épineux et moi me pose un cas de
conscience voyez un cadre éthique car
enfin tu suivais le suivait bien mon
raisonnement parce qu'il est un peu
trapu n'est ce pas eux
si on augmente les primes de risque est
ce que ça ne peut pas laisser croire
qu'en même temps les risques augmentent
aussi
alors moi c'est une chose à laquelle je
ne me résoudrai jamais ce serait bien
trop risqué que vous êtes bon petit bout
que vous êtes bon oui oui oui je suis
bon méchoui et j'aime à vous l'entendre
dire parce que sous le costume croisé il
ya un coeur qui palpite
qu'est ce qui cause bien notre directeur
enfin votre mari on trouve ainsi dire à
michel catherine vincent au makhila de
l'instruction messieurs pour ce qui est
de causer à comme ça mais il a pris des
cours vous savez à quoi de plus
sympathique parce qu'au début
au début il était un peu dur voyez il
était un peu fermé milla qui du moins le
coeur mais si je vous assure thibault
vous été un peu dur au début
six bâtiments il prend des cours il
prend des cours stables à ses premiers
de prendre des cours de calcul parce que
pour les augmentations bonjour bondi de
moi si jamais je dérange vous me dites 1
je vais à côté je fais un peu de
broderie on écoute et yvonne parc de
vous ici alors oui bah justement je
trouve qu'on parle de trop alors servait
donc assez bien servi à tuer c'est
copieux c'est pas comme la cantine
aulas il a l'air plus frais toujours
excuser moi d'en parler c'est peut-être
pas le moment à table ma fac je vous
rappelle quand même qu'on a eu trois
attaques situation alimentaire à la
cantina semaine dernière est ce que ça
ne serait pas les coquillages didon
parce que les huîtres cette année
c'était le nom m'échappe michel
catherine mouchet manger manger michel
catherine un comme ça on aura la paix 1
vous ment vous mangez puisque vote d'elf
et la pose une question qui me brûle les
lèvres
mais écoutez alesi nous sommes là pour
effectuer un tour d'horizon des
problèmes de l'entreprise sur chaussée
corps le dialogue est ouvert
alors monsieur le directeur comment se
fait-il que les cadences sont augmentées
60 pour ça alors qu'elle est salaires
n'ont progressé que de 0 05 %
oui alors comment pouvez-vous
m'expliquer qu'une honnête semaine de 40
heures ne fasse que 39
je n'avais pas pensé à ça ah bah oui bah
oui bah oui mais seulement faut penser
plancher haut et femmes en ce qui
concerne mes camarades de la section
féminine
en ce qui concerne les vestiaires
monsieur director qui vont pour ainsi
dire qu'on voudrait c'est à la suite des
cas besoin
on voudrait des cadenas
oui oui oui oui bien sûr le problème le
problème est important seulement je ne
comprends pas très bien
moi j'avais compris que le prolétariat
était une sorte de grande famille n'est
ce pas je pensais que vous étiez pour
l'autogestion le partage la communauté
alors bon aussi la question de cannes la
bunge ou bien vous les cas là mais j'ai
peur j'ai peur que ça exacerbe un peu
votre votre instinct de propriété qui a
fait déjà tant de vannes
j'ai d'ailleurs d'ailleurs la propriété
c'est le vol ah mais oui c'est oui bah
manger vous
moi je marche je mange je mange de grand
coeur vous savez je suis si contente si
heureuse de nous avoir tous réunis à
cette même table
si on m'avait dit en juin dernier
lorsque nous renier mon mari en otage
que nous travaillerions à la grande
fortune du pauvre jeu catherine où vous
ne devriez pas revenir sur des moments
les souvenirs aussi pénible d'ailleurs
le problème n'est pas là nous assomme à
la concertation
alors est ce que ma pause est finie non
non non vous n'avez pas fini ce que dans
votre assiette mangent les manger mon
jeu les i il tombe à petit ma petit
arlat d'y penser
est-ce que vous en étiez de cette prise
d'otages un peu j'étais même en première
ligne en or même que j'étais sa garde
aux deux corps c'est quoi ça à sa feinte
de corps quoi enfin c'est moi qu'ils en
espèrent ses petits besoins du groupe et
ça j'en prends dans son assiette même il
s'agit en effet de la purée en flocons
d'allumer la laisser sur le bord de
l'assiette en velours pas voulu mais il
est difficile vous savez vous voyez
thibault y'a pas moi qui le dis à busan
difficile à qui on peut bien le dire
maintenant que tu te fini monsieur
thibault l'avait pas toujours les mains
d'un simple
qu'est ce que ça veut dire thibault quoi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire thibault 604
sûr d'en faire mais parfaitement non
faire vous rendez pas compte vous n'y
était pas avec des bolchéviques une
nymphomane et pourquoi vont afficher
national atteint alors pourra faire la
paix sociale nom de dieu passe autrement
au nez dans le caca vous parle a bien
fait de papier me suis planté à 100 km h
est né à madame michèle catherine
couturier ça chez moi le samedi soir mon
père et ma mère quand ils sont bien
pourri qu'est-ce qu'ils se foutent sur
la gueule mais bien sûr mais mais bien
sûr parce que on glose sur les
différences sociales mais y'en a pas il
y en a eu mais y en a plus y en a il y
en a eu il y en a eu sa peau et encore
depuis quand mon grand père disait on
est tous nés avec le même trou de balle
comment
mais bien mieux bien sûr et bien sûr à
l'envoyons à l'eau mais n'aura eu le
mérite de ma petite ma petite michelle
catherine aller dont nous chercher le
gâteau un jeu supporte pas ce porto et
le nabab likes symevad jinan et puis ce
match et on a vu on a vu ben on n'a pas
vu quelques fois c'est pire vous savez
c'est notre usine
oui c'est pourquoi vous suffisait à
celle usine de thibault en maille en
nougatine puisqu'il marié là c'est moi
en pâte d'amande et on sait qu'il est
l'atelier bk temps mais ça c'est une
idée fixe on vous a dit qu'il était
sucré annoncé la machine à café et à
leon es18 qu'il entend écouter cette
machine à café ça nous gâchent va se
marrer je vous en prie faites un effort
thibault avec nous ses bénéfices
scandaleux vous avez réalisé et
dissimulation
si ça pouvait briser les traits des yeux
des cheveux coupés nous le gardons vous
pour une fois qu'on peut partager le
gâteau
tu veux quoi l'être les vestiaires à la
cantine
tiens moi je pomme gêné fronton des
ateliers
bravo c'est intelligent quand ils font
ça en vrai vous régalerez - ont écouté
dit bouanou pas touche à votre bureau ou
alors tenez prenez dit manat main michel
et catherine j'ai une question qui me
vient j'aimerais bien croquer monsieur
thibault par thibaut un os mais vous
aviez raison ce sont des cannibales ou
leur donne ça ils veulent sa fortune en
remettait tout une cuisine de mon mari
dans la salle il en est pas question ont
gardé un avantage acquis à la loge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]